so I really get into this you know
sentence hi there Steve coffin here and
today I want to talk about a theme that
I've discussed before and that is the
sort of combination of big picture
learning and nuts and bolts learning in
in language learning so if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe click on
the bell for notifications and if you
follow me on a podcast service which I
recommend especially if you're learning
English uh please leave a comment
I should say that that the ability to
listen to interesting content whether it
be in the language you're learning or
even in content of interest to you in
your own language is so powerful the
quality of the audio the range of
material that's out there right now I'm
listening to a English language book
from audible called American psychosis
which traces the history of sort of
right-wing hysterical movements in the
United States and it's very interesting
so sometimes I take a break from
listening to Arabic and I listen to the
book while I'm doing the dishes now
getting back to the subject of big
picture learning and nuts and bolts
learning so for me Arabic is difficult
uh it's difficult for a number of
reasons I think first of all it's it's
written in the Arabic script which is
still difficult for me it has more
complicated grammar than Persian because
it has masculine feminine it has you
know one you know dual like plural and
then completely plural it has a number
of sort of somewhat more finicky details
of grammar than say Persian which is
more similar to what we're familiar to
in Indo-European languages an additional
difficulty with Arabic is that there are
different uh forms of Arabic so there's
Egyptian Arabic there's Levant in Arabic
and of course North African Arabic and
Gulf Arabic and Iraqi Arabic and yemeni
I don't know so many different forms of
the language
and because I like to access the
language and the culture in so many
different ways then political
discussions by and large are going to be
in Standard Arabic but I found the MTV
Lebanon which is also political
discussion but it's in Lebanese or
levantine Arabic movies typically on
Netflix or most of them are either in uh
you know they're either from Lebanon or
from Egypt so I'm I want to have some
sense of those languages so I'm really
studying three languages Standard Arabic
11th in Arabic and Egyptian Arabic and I
even got a book that compares levantine
Arabic to Egyptian Arabic getting back
to MTV Lebanon which is quite difficult
they're having these political
discussions and there's again with
Arabic there's so much more vocabulary
in Arabic
it seems so much more you need more
vocabulary than in Persian has been my
experience for whatever reason so it
looks like a
constant uphill battle
and I'm wondering if I've if I'm
actually getting anywhere so what I do
is so I've started doing this now with
the material from MTV Lebanon which by
the way I download the MP3 file I put
the MP3 file on Happy scribe I get a
transcript I upload the whole thing into
link as a lesson then I go through it in
sentence mode now right away by going in
and going through sentence mode I'm
starting to slow things down the the big
picture would be just to listen to the
whole thing read through the whole thing
not understand as much as I would like
it seems like a you know a real uphill
struggle
sisyphean task so to speak but if I go
through sentence by sentence then I look
up each word I can then review you know
have sort of vocabulary review
activities for that sentence which could
be three or four items of vocabulary
using matching pairs then I can
reassemble the sentence also I can
listen to the audio several times so I
really get into this
you know sentence of course a sentence
is a sample of the language and so I
don't do this the whole time but I'll do
this for a fair amount of the time
because if I can break if I can get into
if I can break the code of the sentence
get a better sense of the structure get
a better especially now dealing with you
know Lebanese dialect and some of the
words that they're using so I get into
some depth with each sentence and I
listen to it quite a few times but it
would take it takes a long time to get
through the whole 30 or 45 or 50 minutes
of this uh you know radio interview or
television interview uh you know going
sentence by sentence reviewing all the
words you know reassembling the
sentences so I don't do it all the way
through but it's a sample it reminds me
of when we were we were making lumber
for a very large prefabricated house
manufacturer in Japan we had very strict
quality standards not size you know
twist Bend uh you know cracks in the
good whatever we had very very strict
standards so we would you know take a
hundred pieces out of the line every
hour and just to check on the quality
and that sample representative sort of
what was in the wood that we were
processing because presumably the wood
that we were using the sort of raw
material would have been of a you know
one sort of origin and so to some extent
the quality of the hundred pieces that
we took out was representative of the
quality of the whole run and in the same
way
I feel very often if I can do this sort
of in-depth nuts and bolts learning for
a sample percentage of this content it
helps me when I do the sort of big
picture listening to the whole thing
reading the whole thing similarly
similarly uh as I'm going through my uh
you know lesson this uh television
interview from MTV Lebanon it takes me a
long time to look up every single word
and to check every single single yellow
word that is a word that I've looked up
before and so at some point I say okay
rather than read through the whole thing
which for me reading in Arabic is still
much slower than reading in the Latin
alphabet so at some point maybe halfway
through
I start to skip so I skip from Blue word
to Yellow word the yellow word the blue
words are really only looking up the
words that I either don't know because I
haven't seen them before or that I'm
still not really that familiar with even
though I've seen them maybe three four
five six times so I look those up again
so I'm just jumping from unknown word or
not fully you know understood word and
going through the text that way I still
and so that's a kind of a nuts and bolts
sampling of the vocabulary but I still
listen to the whole thing and to some of
the words that I you know in my sampling
looked up some of those I remember some
of them I noticed when I listen but it's
not a hundred percent and so much of
language learning is not a hundred
percent but it's a sampling so I can go
through you know sentence by sentence
reassembling sentences getting a better
grasp of the structure of the language
getting a better grasp of some
vocabulary items then I might speed up
the sampling by skipping from word to
word
but I still listen to the whole thing so
I'm combining nuts and bolts with you
know big picture learning and I I think
you know this is something I recommend
that you find your own combination and
your own way of combining I I should
while I think of it another form of nuts
and bolts learning is to look up grammar
issues things that your you know
questions that you have in your mind
about why it works this way in that way
and there's so many resources for doing
that so just to finish up here so I
think it's important to have a
combination have a strategy your own
strategy uh where you combine the nuts
and bolts with the top-down learning you
still need to do a lot of top like big
picture learning lots of reading lots of
listening but you also need to spend
some time on the nuts and bolts so there
you go thank you for listening bye for
now